ça va avec ça va franchement ça va mais
c'est vrai c'est pourquoi pourquoi parce
que je suis premier à venir deux fois
deux fois de suite c'est vrai tu as aux
privilèges des secours il est monsieur
là je veux pas le faire son temps c'est
vrai c'est en gros je me suis dit [ __ ]
ça serait drôle pour noël de se demander
un truc et du père noël toile permet
d'exister tout élu qui a fait une vidéo
là dessus la nr et moi j'existe est bon
pour t'appeler quoi alors deux choses la
première c'est que c'était ya deux ans
la vie à deux ans et la deuxième c'est
qu'en fait il ya dix ans et de poker
annoncé il ya trois ans le canada suit
en soi même ses trois ans c'est pas
grave et de deux j'ai fait en fait
j'avais fait des petites petites
coquilles dans la vidéo en fait nos
qu'elle a pas mal de mes calculs étaient
en fait faut donc finalement bon bah je
peux peut-être partir maintenant cette
maman reste parce qu'on a besoin en
revanche ça m'intéresse de d'imaginer
cette question cette fameuse question la
semaine générique pas à auquel au québec
lorsque génériques je gère ton émission
en fait ça marche
t'imagines si ya pas encore de
génériques mais ça arrive surtout
n'oubliez pas de prendre un petit et
boissons sont à le mecque et chaud aux
logiques et chaud carrément pété ou bien
mettez vous à l'aise en plus c'est jour
de noël aux enfants nous mais pour vous
oui mais pour vous oui normalement on a
des surprises et des surprises et des
surprises
t'imagines si le père noël existe et que
l'on se fait assumant fait de ce pôle et
200 mille personnes auraient put un mec
était que ça c'est le truc est revenu le
plus souvent dans les commentaires je
vraiment extrêmement désolé j'ai vu ce
pôle est surprise par la non existence z
c'est chaud mais je suis désolé quand
c'est chaud mais ça se trouve avec la
vidéo on va se rendre compte que
il existe dans l'église ce qu on
pourrait se rencontrent ça donc produit
se rendre compte que [ __ ] heureusement
qu'ils existent pas cool tu es jeune tu
prêt c'est de rêver à ces conclusions
du coup les principes je connais bien
parce que j'ai mis mon bonnet j ai pas
de bonnet de noël à moi j'en ai un an
plus avant des symboles et igloofest du
canada gimbrède jean monnet de
l'igloofest avaient scandé partir
qu'elle dorme temps et brew quoi ben
voyons pas le prendre
vous voyez je reviens à tout de suite on
pourrait demander ce qu'on veut à noël
du coup le commerce de noël sur une
foutue est ce que vraiment content que à
noël le père noël et offrent ce que tu
veux pour élever liste dans maman de
féministes mais t'es sur que c'est pas
je leur impose qui veut quoi je crois
qu'il prend un trident maïs parce que
dans les films et où des fois il donne
des nounours ok moi je pense que le père
noël et il est en bisbille avec amazon
est tous bords des jo clairement si moi
je veux une ps4
je le mets sur ma liste le père noël il
va demander à souligner dit ps4 ça fait
retourner bref oui pour moi le commerce
ça changerait un commerce de noël en
soit n'en suivra un distributeur et
surtout voilà c'est ça c'est exactement
ça c'est comme amazon d un service de
livraison les femmes chronopost
en fait ça changera rien dans le sens où
tout l'esprit restera là toi on achète
réclament des guirlandes
moi j'aimerais quand même nous a fait
cadeau pour mes même plus parce que le
père noël existe quoi vraiment faire un
accueil grave du coup on aurait tous une
cheminée on aura tous la petite
chaussette je ne sais pas mais ça se
rendre du coup la chine et serait
obligatoire ce qui serait pas mal enfin
un peu dangereux aussi mais une bonne
cheminée franchement sous toutes les
maisons auraient des conduits pourquoi
alors tu étais quand tu la vis d'apple
donc pour le père noël évidemment
vous êtes toutes occupées enfin la
féclaz c'est énorme ça ou alors tu
arrives dans un parti c'est un [ __ ]
donc tu vas pas là il a fallu
reconstruire le grand duékoué ouest et à
nous remettre un peu de gameplay mois
d'école est reconduit ça arrive dans ce
train très ambitieux et très bien
d'accord c'est qu'ils font a dit ça on
est sûr de l express d'accord guidage
des mois c'est pas les médias au père
noël de poing rip les ressources de
matières premières mondiales bah oui ce
que je pense qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
consommables une faute parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui n'ont pas les moyens
de s'acheter des cadeaux de noël qui l'a
du cours et des cadeaux parce qu'ils ont
des sages quoi non plus le permet
l'analyse votre dépense en kérosène les
coupés sait pas de quoi il gardera pas
par moi j'avais chez moi quand j'ai lu
ça ça me fait c'est ça qui met plus
direct en tête puisque rien imaginer
tous les chinois les indiens toute
l'afrique et tout qui peut-être moins de
cadeaux à noël d'habitude
las il n'en est rien c'est con non
j'avoue on dans les favelas ça va ça va
tomber contre et tant mieux
et en même temps mes héros et victimes
pour les ressources est ce qu elles
cesseront le permet il serait écolo
responsable écolo responsable
je pense à ma ville fait ses petits
papiers cadeaux en fibre de bambou ya
moyen way est d'accord et et puis à
tampa bay il fait route parce que
j'attends on a dit à l'ats que c'était
un distributeur mais messieurs le thym
dans la légende mais voilà il trouva
brigue pas un chat je crois qu'ils
fabriquent ils ont des petits tapis
roulant autour du cou pour revenir sur
les questions de commerce de noël
si les lutins fabrique bas du cou et 10
ans est tombé un peu le commerce
si l'élu a par rapport à la question
précédente
ouais ouais carrément mais du coup ça va
être meilleur mais désaccord je
considère d accord ce que ra8 un peut
pas construire une ps4 sans l'accord de
sony enfin tu as une contrefaçon
oui donc y aurait des accords bilatéraux
entre le père noël et tous les toutes
les grosses entreprises du monde avait
du coup de fabrique collet
truc en bois des machins des titres ont
détruit des trucs de merde qu'on permet
tait de l'ours c'est juste pour les
autres n'ont pas d'idée en fait c'est
clair parce que généralement tu en fais
toi place est écrivain et journaliste
fait foi plaisent mais en vrai c'est
vrai que c'est un petit prince coup aux
matières premières en france et
notammment niveau carburant c'est vrai
qu'il doit pomper le mec un [ __ ] de
ses compos et cherbourg mais ça doit y
aller franchement parce que son règne
ou alors c'est rennes je sais pas ce
qu'ils bouffent oui mais en tout cas
j'aimerais bien en faire une entrée plat
dessert veut ok on part se mettent à 38
et là tu vas prouver un argument pour
dire que c'est pas plus mal que le père
mais ne s'était pas peut-être alors si
c'est lui qui confectionnent les cadeaux
du début à la fin même les ps4 et où tu
vois effectivement commencé au début le
mec dictateur quoi il délivre ses
cadeaux tout en notant n'a pas parce que
tu as été méchant machin le mec fait ça
doit quoi susciter un [ __ ] commence à
rêver de nantes a pas été sage si
j'étais ça je regardais touché marche
pas envie alessio en fait le mec il ya
en fait il faudrait signer en fait ce qu
il faudrait je pansse avant de dit
croire ou pas si les fins il existe on
il n'y a pas besoin d'y croire ou pas on
y croit il existe il faut signer une
charte de confidentialité quoi parce que
le mec ça veut dire qu'il a le le
pouvoir divin de voir tout ce que tu
fais j'aurais eu accès à ton compte
facebook twitter voir site a été gentil
ou page
donc moi je sais pas si je le
souhaiterais quoi concrètement et des
choses j'ai pas envie qu'il voit aucun
changement et toi non ils voyent peut
voir tous et partout ouais mais mais
parce que toi sont ces derniers il veut
garde pour lui et c'est clair mais ward
[ __ ] pas ouais mais faille et le
garde pour lui mais quelque part ça se
sait quoi
genre tu as tes potes qui viennent à
telco pour noble âge a rien eu qu'est ce
que tu as fait qu'est ce que tu as fais
toi
après cholet c'est fou ce qu'on paye ce
combat de cadeaux vraiment ils ont fait
des temps de réponse et la mère de
famille âgée et où le menton gâteau et
le petit dernier quand elle n'a pas eu
bixi
je rends compte qu'en fait le soir il va
sur kto sirius black et baraki zuway
safia moyen de prouver leur bonne foi
billy pas assez clair ce serait drôle
aussi simple que la valeur du cadeau
dépendent d'eux mais quel point tu n as
well as sera énorme ça serait énorme
genre est énorme puisque tu as fait mais
qu'est ce que tu as fait unique
je vais pas dire ne pas me dire ce que
le mec il a une mustang et côté moi je
vais sauver le peuple de macha gspc et
sa loterie grippe ça la fout mal
si le père noël existe et il serait
hyper fatigue après mais après il se
prépare toute l'année pour juste cette
nuit là bas mon avis toute l'année il
fabrique des jouets à quoi ces lutteurs
vicquois la fabrique est fabriquée
l'organisation ouais ouais y voir un
chef de projet avec le père noël et la
petite carte ils voient ce qu'elles sont
il fait son travail normalement ce que
tout soit genre c'est plutôt avortements
en fait je moi je le vois bien genre
toute l'année s'entraîner physiquement
et où machin juste le soir de noël où il
faut qu'il soit incroyable chasse est
plus apte et je viens les genres ces
genres ses lutins du père noël
ok t il est élu on lui fout de l'eau et
au machin t on lui prépare ses trucs des
massages et thomas jadis comme un
sportif quoi qu'il fasse ou légères et
père noël auquel à lui dire recul du
titre le tut il est moyen mais à mon
avis et ouais parce que du coup je
serais pas du tout cette grosse bête et
valence 18e en fait mais voilà ses
satires in cheul père noël je pense
c'est le père noël existe est il serait
aussi l'auteur d'un superbe bouquin de
gestion des stocks
je pense que oui
clermont le galéré montferrand cette
fête tout sépare tout ce que tu veux et
les profs et les méchants 13 professeurs
et tous les tubes attaquant quoi si le
gardien existait toutes les grandes
entreprises et les pays du monde ferait
tout pour avoir la technologie qui
permet de
j'ai bien vite par conséquent il doit
sûrement avoir sa propre armée
personnelle pour se défendre
on va regarder comment deux lutins
l'enfer l'enfer bon gars ça fait trop
flipper j'ai trop peur d'eux à un troll
quoi y voit trop l'égalité à la cm
[ __ ] encore cette année le père noël
va frapper il faut qu'on sache comment
il fait moi je trouve les lutins avec
des arcs taille pour les accueillir tous
en or en mai mais c'est pas des
meurtriers et vitaly se mentir les
sondages
par contre j'ai pu de circulation
sanguine au niveau du client afin de
choisir
tu as ça va je commence à les dures du
type sol c'est rassurant ces provinces
et des spas dur c'est plutôt bien
c'est un peu sa fonction première au
même titre que iron man ne possèdent des
voix un armement une technologie de ouf
le gouvernement peut sont inspirés ils
veulent il veut tu vois là les voir
comment ça se passerait pas par contre
ce serait vachement possible afin que
avec toute la pression du monde sur les
épaules du père noël que le mec et
limogeant cette technologie fuite en
trekking wya lindo quoi voilà un scoop
ram
en fait la cei a envoyé un aqua
résultats lui ont mis un bonnet rouge
il ya du beau jeu tap et choukook tu te
fais passer pour un lutin tu te ramasses
à george duke pouvez les suivre
opposition à l'état qu'aux proches cook
ok alors là je suis dans l'entrepôt le
temps mais elle arrive terminé à tenter
d'aider les temps car je me verrais ce
citizen qui parce qu'il est vous êtes
nouveau vous oui oui c'est dans la
cargaison 12 je suis dans la veine du
paul doyle bien après la très bien
bienvenue vous avez bon et la série tous
il fait tomber son chapeau et envoie sa
gauvreau une patate en france la barre
mais ils tous fabriqués chez williams le
mec il a dit oui voilà super d'exister
cela remettrait les croyances
religieuses et philosophiques
c'est un peu comme si on nous apprenait
que dieu existait de façon concrète web
et le commutateur voici un petit lait un
peu tout puissant se trouve dieu c'est
lui quoi en fait c'est vrai que là ce
qui change avec le père noël par rapport
à beaucoup d'autres choses c'est que
c'est une personne 3 tu dis s'il ya une
personne qui est capable de faire un
truc aussi puissant gang starr sahara
vers un peu en jeu le culte de la
personnalité et les supérieurs qu avec
des voiles et et les puissants mais
supérieur à l'espèce humaine on aime ça
et nous effectuerons et du coup ça ça
ouvrait la brèche mais je pense que en
fait en fait quoi et on est de religion
autour du viendrait le nom est lisse
mais mes mecs vraiment je pense et des
gens qui toute l'année prierai pour père
noël et pour essayer d'être sage et
avoir des cadeaux c'est un machin et de
religion au temps du carnet j'avoue mais
est ce que quand le quand le dieu est
vivant et visible est-ce qu'on est ce qu
on le hait ce qu'on l'admiré est ce
qu'on le prix autant comme toi est ce
que le fait qu'on le voit pas fait qu'on
a une croyance en verre en vers sète
cette entité plus puissante voix le
alors je pense que tout dépend de la
gestion du marketing du père noël
célèbre aussi le père noël décide de
se montrait vachement et c'est d'avoir
un compte twitter ce genre de structure
et ben ouais effectivement tu as raison
je pense que le le shérif les moins on
le vénère vraiment mais si le mec il
ajoute daft punk c'est jackpot
j'avoue j'avoue tu vas genre il apparaît
qu'une fois par an il s'instaure monde
garde tu l'entends temps plupart
aiguille en mieux que ça mec tu le
voiture tu te lèves en fait tu vois
juste ses jambes partir de tâches mines
et ses délires et après tu regarde par
la fenêtre je le kiffe trop c'est clair
tout le monde en un père noël un peu
comme j'écouterai tous ses albums mais
je pense qu'avoir je pense qu'avoir une
grosse de barres blanches
ce sera la botte de hook quoi ce serait
même obligatoire en fait ouais enfin pas
obligatoire mais conseille pas dans le
dos élise parent vaut mieux quoi il est
veuf jean les mêmes elle symbolise
d'avoir une barbe blanche qui s'est
passé tellement bon mais g et que
j'adore tout le temps faire ça avec toi
j'espère vraiment que le prochain en
fait je regarde que le prochain ça avec
moi encore bengale franchement j'adore
j'adore ce format mecque et c'est
toujours un plaisir véhicule très très
cool ça fait vachement plaisir c'est
cool mec merci même c'est la base tu
comptais sur 20 pour l'achat des
chiffres et où plus que je n'ai pas ça
me fait kiffer mais je suis sûr que je
vais essayer de trouver des liens de
gens qui ont fait des calculs sur un
machin et je les mettrai en descriptions
pas les miens mais est ce que est ce que
vu que vu que t'as pas pu sortir des
chiffres est ce que ta part d'autres
trucs être que tu pourrais qui pourrait
sortir du coup tu veux dire genre à
taper effecté pas sur tes pieds comme un
espèce de cadeaux à ça ça me fait
plaisir ça tu veux dire comme ça par
exemple à faire avec ça c'est ton je
t'avais un jeu de société
en fait un jeu de société qu'est sorti à
il ya un mois oui j'ai senti un mois et
dans les bons temps et où j'en suis
grâve content mexès est le fruit de
plusieurs longs mois de travail avec
avec mes potes
equidia avec jérémy avec piquionne donc
on est grave comptant à quoi sert tout
comme on adore les jeux de société on en
fait souvent très souvent des soirées
d'une société ansamble l'on joue plus à
son biceps et des jeux billard quand
j'avais 15 ans vise balade on appris
on adore ce jeu et ça c'est un jeu
collaboratif justement un peu comme
celui ci dont une conque le plateau en
mots et grave qui font quoi donc voilà
et est ce que tu penses que je peux
offrir à mes abonnés mais grave mec
viril et ça me fait grand plaisir toi
c'est ta vidéo et je vais jouer mon jeu
c'est gentil gentil ça c'est toi qui es
gentil de les filets donc c'est ce qu'on
va faire dans veut plus d'europe
tu comprends ça mais si jamais temps de
3,4 pc je suis reparti avec ba est ce
que je peux les laisser là pour enfants
et les parents après mais ça dépend
quand tu veux les faire gagner comme ça
que ça sans appel je vais pas gagner un
jour une semaine après le raid en jeu
mais tu vois je vais je pense que je
vais me laisser tous avantages institués
en dur et si tu vas en prendre 4 5 2
ben vas-y je peux l'entendre chaud pour
faire gagner 5 ok sache que ça te
coupera mais ces deux euros par mois
ouais j'en fais regagné 1 et 20 à
laisser mon cadeau de noël à ses abonnés
je sais pas encore comment je vais faire
gagner mais du coup tout sera expliqué
mouvement sur facebook il faut laver ma
page aller sur le poste de la vidéo m je
participe et maître ckoi noël pour toi
il ya un jeu à gagner sur twitter il
faut me suivre si tu es le tweet de la
vidéo avec pour hashtag cyrus north et
dr bossman il ya un jeu à gagner aussi
sur snapshot il ya deux jeux à gagner
c'est la rapidité
il faut me suivre il y aura deux
instants win le gagnant ou la gagnante
sera la première personne à me répondre
et sur instagram ya un jeu à gagner
aussi
il faut me suivre et légendes et ma
dernière photo ça se passe sur le compte
si le sort d'ailleurs tout ça c'est à
chaque fois ci le jeune ans tout attaché
pour trouver les infos et le concours se
termine en 2016 c'est à dire le temps
t1 décembre à 23h59 et en tout cas merci
beaucoup mais qu à la barre c'est pour
les cadeaux c'est liverpool
j'espère que vous allez kiffer ce sera
le temps que moi je sors tu sais moi ça
serait bien que je sorte un truc aussi
moi j'aime être utilisé que newey g2
grosse envie d'écrire des crédits soit
un petit truc soit il faut faire quelque
chose ou thé je réfléchis à la scène
jean paul bret j'ai bien fait un trou
dans la vraie vie pendant la fête aurait
pas fait hier un peu ta première
représentation
si style et j'ai trop aimé voir ça mais
d'ailleurs j'ai hâte de voir si la
parloir cool et merci d'être venus c'est
les mafias tour des deux leaders sont
pas venus ouais mais tu es du son mach
est allé chez moi exactement et c'était
hyper cool pour la prochaine question
elle est maintenant je vous répondais
ici dans les commentaires de cette vidéo
la question là voilà tu imagines si la
mythologie grecque
c'était de l'histoire avec ma nombril de
la chaîne c'est une autre histoire et je
fais de gros gros bisous abonnez-vous à
la chaîne de dr naman au dossier russie
il fait des trucs incroyables en ce
moment j'aime beaucoup ton nouveau
format l'engagement qu'a pris la
tournure que prend ta chaîne et enfin
bref c'est à dire fais ce que tu veux
dire et ont à ce jour là dessus si mon
plus beau cadeau de noël aux efforts
qu'il reste à lutter dans sa tasse passé
un très bon noël avec avec vos amis
votre famille très aisée mais sa
présence vous aimez ou même tout seul au
bisou et est passé de bonnes fêtes
on vous aime ciao ciao l'année prochaine